well we'll keep going obviously for as
long as as we can and
i think what
people should also understand is what an
incredible achievement this has been by
the uk military just in the last
10 days or so
the the operation of pitting has brought
airlifted 15 000 people uh to this
country from afghanistan uh there's been
nothing like it in terms of speed and
scale uh in our in our lifetime
certainly in my in my memory and that's
equivalent to the a town the size of uh
of beckham's field or or prestwick or
abigail or amar and uh
obviously
there's a huge amount of work now going
on to make sure that we
find homes find ways of integrating
those people into
this country
but we owe them a debt and they're
people who looked after
our armed forces uh helped uh for the 20
years of the uk's engagement in
afghanistan it's absolutely the right
thing to do and
we've got the overwhelming majority of
those to whom we owe that debt out of
afghanistan as i stand and talk to you
now in the time we have left which may
be as i'm sure everybody can appreciate
uh quite short we'll do everything we
can to get everybody else but i want to
stress
that this is just the first phase
so even beyond the
the us deadline of the of the 31st of uh
of this month
we hope
to continue to be able to say to people
well you can uh you can come out and one
of the the key things that we're saying
to the to the taliban to the the
government uh the the new authorities in
in kabul is to engage with the west to
unlock uh those funds safe passage is
for those who want to come out is
obviously the number one condition
but you're telling people to keep away
from kabul airport how great is the
security threat
i think we have to be transparent about
the
the risks and we have to be uh realistic
about uh what's going on
and you'll you'll appreciate that uh
there are uh islamic state coruscant
province uh terrorists out there
uh
i can't go into the into the details
clearly but we have to be mindful of the
security of uh of our uh personnel but
also of of the afghan uh people who are
trying to to get out but what i would
stress
is that we're coming now towards the end
of this phase
in any event in the sense that we've
already airlifted out of
afghanistan a a huge number of people
more than it's the biggest operation uh
of its kind uh in in decades and i think
everybody i want to stress this thing
everybody
involved the the uk
military uh
everybody involved at the airport
everybody who's been helping us they
should be incredibly proud of what
they've achieved there's a suggestion
that people who can't get to the airport
should head to borders but if the
taliban haven't agreed to that that
could be hugely dangerous
i want to just go back to what i was
saying about phase one and and and and
phase two of
the future beyond august the 31st and
just to stress that
we think that
we've got the overwhelming majority of
those eligible under the uh the eligible
person scheme or under the the rap
scheme the the afghan repatriation and
assistance program both those schemes we
think we've we've done the lion's share
there will be people uh who still need
help but what we're hoping
and uh
this is the key point that the the g7
agreed is that the taliban understand
that if they want to engage uh with you
know development aid if they want to
unlock uh those billions of
funds they want to have a diplomatic a
political relationship with the outside
world then you know safe passage uh for
for those who want to come out is the
key precondition are you advising people
to go to borders
the advice people should look at the the
current advice the advice at the moment
is that
the security situation is is obviously
not improving
but we've got the overwhelming majority
out and
what i would say is i see a second phase
when
we hope very much that the taliban will
understand that there's got to be a
reasonable approach to
people who still want to to leave
afghanistan but i i would just repeat
the i sometimes i think people realize
the immensity
of what the uk military have already
helped to achieve this is you know this
is uh as i say
a sizable
uk town of
afghans who've risked their lives uh in
many cases to help the uk are now coming
to the uk actually in most cases are now
here
the real job now is to make sure that
they have the housing they have the the
the skills they have the opportunities
to integrate into our society as you
know uh our labor market uh currently
offers many opportunities uh but we must
make sure that they're they're ready and
that's another whole job of work i've
got time to ask one other issue is
universal credit
two mps have written to you saying that
it shouldn't the 20-pound uplift should
remain and they're really concerned that
that will go
what do you say to them
the key focus for this government is on
making sure that we we we come out of
covid uh strongly with uh with a
jobs-led recovery and i'm very pleased
to see the the way the the unemployment
numbers the unemployment numbers have
been forming
employment numbers have been rising but
also wages have been rising and that's a
crucial thing
i'm proud that we've uh bumped up the
the living wage we've continually
increased the living wage last time by a
record amount and my preference my
strong strong preference and i believe
that this is
the instinct to most people in this
country my strong preference is for
people uh to see their wages rise uh
through their efforts rather than uh
through uh taxation of other people put
into their uh into their pay packets and
uh rather than than welfare and that's
the that's the approach we support i've
got time for one final one on
afghanistan um lots of people very
concerned about pen filing and his
animals have you or even your wife had
any direct contact with him about
getting them out i've had absolutely no
influence on any a particular case nor
would that be
right that's not that's not how we do
things in this country but what i can i
can certainly say is that uh all what we
will certainly make sure is that uh and
there have been some heart-rending cases
i've just been looking at uh some of the
emails that have been coming in from
people in in afghanistan who have helped
us to whom we owe these these debts of
honor and obligation and it's it's
fantastic to see the way uh that we're
we're helping them but we've got to do
it uh impartially and uh and that's what
that's what we're doing and as i say we
we've so far thanks to this
extraordinary operation uh we've helped
the the overwhelming majority of people
in in both the categories and we're
going to use the remaining
time to do as many more as we possibly
can but as i as
i keep saying that's not the end of the
story thank you very much thank you